franck krawczyk on se retrouve on était
abandonnés la dernière fois vous noterez
cité pas suivant c'est à dire que marc
entier au fond que vous êtes quelqu'un
qui a tout commence et qui a fait tout
fait très bien et puis kaka craquer où
le haut plutôt le clavier ou la porte
c'est à dire que vous avez commencé le
piano et puis un jour vous êtes dit non
c'est pas ça que je veux faire et la
composition vous êtes vous êtes donc au
conservatoire de lyon est là alors que
toutes les portes s'ouvrent au pérou
pour vous on commande une neuve vous
avez 20 ans l'a commencé à tourner le
dos à ça aussi oui disons que c'est ça
je me reconnais dans la critique qu'on
peut faire pour le coup on va enlever le
mot critique pour que ce soit plus
audible pour mon milieu mais on va dire
le questionnement profond enfin c'est à
dire l'impasse dans laquelle langage
le langage musical contemporain s'est
mis ses billes s'est mis volontairement
dans une situation où il est coupé du
langage ordinaire commun c'est-à-dire
qu'on parle pas le sérialisme parle pas
d'eux des capots nice ne part pas la
musique spectrale pourquoi qu'on peut
encore imaginer ça mais on parle une
langue un peu étrangère au monde dans
lequel on vit
bon c'est le rêve d'une impasse saint
quentin vite
cette délibération après cela les rats
trice c'est compliqué c'est un paradis
parce que c'est une impasse et je n'ai
pas de vous il n'est pas forcément beau
n'est pas forcément vous de parler
forcément
la langue ordinaire ce à dire que c'est
pas mais tant que ça reste lié en tout
cas c'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire
quelque chose qui est on revient à
l'accordéon une expérience vécue pour
moi que je peux partager avec n'importe
qui s'il ya quelque chose de simple
bon c'était possible mais quand les
langages contemporains devient ce qui
est beaucoup cas souvent une étude sur
lui-même dans les rues ça tourne rond ça
devient quelque chose que je ne peux pas
et il est vrai il est vrai que c'est là
où je ne j'ai calé j'ai calé quoi parle
aux deux 2 course f puisque vous théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines y aura
trois grands concerts notamment en fin
de compte être le maître d'oeuvre le
premier ses répétitions
c'est des compositions pour divers
instruments et là nous avez fait
là alors c'est le compositeur qu'on
retrouve quand même whisky c'est un
compilateur de musique cours d'eau c'est
presque le résumé de ce qu on sera
content parce que je prends une pièce
qui est très simple
d'apparence à dire j'écris une ligne
pour un instrument quel corps pourquoi
ça me fascine le corps on embête homme
n'en va pas
ça c'est le corps
et entre les cordes
enfants c'était pas un corps c'était pas
ça c'était juste la clé couvrir un
espace il ment dans la maison c'était
juste le transport
je ne veux pas que ça fasse une anecdote
parce que mais ça va faire une anecdote
tant pis je veux dire si je vais non
n'importe quelle personne qui était au
ski un jour dans sa vie et qui
c'est qui rentre un peu tard
et qui voit le soleil décline et ouais
c'est pas la situation le bit homme j'ai
bien conscience 1 1 mais
qui sent que là encore on a la
perception de quelque chose qui le
soleil qui réchauffe et ça vient de
passer ces instantanés vous avez le
corps
l'affinerie lundi matin
et au sang qui font rentrer
en
et là c'est un autre espace qui sous moi
je n'ai que ça à raconter c'est à dire
que je trouve que les espaces qui
s'ouvrent voilà après les autres les
perspectives exactement donc j'ai fait
une pièce
avec le corps qu'est
où
ça faut l'entendre encore mieux
et chaque
chaque accord que vous entendez
on cherche un espace pratique à tort
leur jeu comme un jazzman cherchera une
couleur pas
en sa je fais quelque chose de très
simple qui et quand debussy mais une
mélodie
dans le vide
une fois il harmonise
et après l'âge elle
très froide
mais là pas bougé y a pas bougé il y a
juste 1 1 31e ce soleil qui a fait 1 mm
à ce jeu et on est ailleurs ouais on est
passé d'un atelier de vie du ski à
autre chose donc pour moi ce sentiment
que la musique en faisant le minimum
d'effort ans le minimum de gestes le
minimum peut ouvrir des espaces
totalement différent c'était le corps
est alors là je dis rentrer dans le lard
l'intellectualisme c'est à dire que le
corps est un instrument magique pour ça
d'accord mais il n'y a pas plus quand il
ya eu aussi une batterie et aussi de la
guitare électrique y alors voilà c'est à
dire que je sais pas suffisant pour moi
ça a l'air à partir du moment où j'ai ça
ça ouvre des espaces aussi sociaux je
dire que ça au début ça ouvre sur la rue
les espaces sont pas que la montagne le
ski ça ouvre
le métro ça ouvre tout ce que vous
voudrez c'est une porte pour vous dire
vous savez bien vous passez d'un état
vous êtes dans une rame de métro sur
bond et puis vous avez un musicien s'il
est bon team bouchons qui peut d'un seul
coup vous rêvez pas ce que ça change
notre rencontre la femme de votre vie
est
inversement aussi dans la cohue aussi
donc pour moi ces choses-là inclure
groupe de rock c'est à dire qu'ils sont
absolument partie prenante de ces
ouvertures la suffit de trouver la bonne
clé est là ce concert c'est vraiment
pour moi une aubaine parce que j'ai
rencontré ce groupe de rock qui a
finalement qui partagent le même le même
oui parce qu'ils ont vécu ils ont ils
ont vécu le paradoxe d'être dans des
femmes nées dans une dans des familles
où il y avait du piano où il y avait du
répertoire classique et en en voulant
pas
quand même un peu au bout d'une autre
manière pour une autre montée je me dis
donc il ya une complicité
je suis désolé je vous presse un petit
peu mais je voudrais quand même qu'on
parle aussi de du deuxième concert parce
que c'est important enfin c'est parfum
de scandale donc c'est berg schoenberg
et berne c'est alors ces demandes visent
la décence de la musique contemporaine
enfin oui
mais ces cas là il est donc c'est un
concert qui fait scandale que vous avez
adapté
oui c'est à dire c'est des parfums
scandale parce que ce concert de 13 de
1913 est un concert où pour la première
fois on va dire ces deux années-là
scandale août manière ces années où il
ya eu tous les scandales possible image
peut-être cv comme ça est bon mais dans
mon dos oui enfin voilà pour l analyse
et ce après il faudra du temps mais on
sait on peut très bien le penser mais
c'est quand même un constat concerne
hallucinant puisque le public a
finalement je crois envahi la scène et a
fait que ça après c'est une la chanteuse
le chanteur qui était un chanteur qui
n'a pas pu se dégager et ses contres
lors qu est ce qu a pas pu sortir donc
il ya une espèce de cohue générale qui a
abouti à ce que les plus les policiers
les émeutes un étouffement de deux ou
trois personnes qui sont retrouvés à
l'hôpital je sais même pas si après un
mort dans l'histoire face à fait les
petits dribbles mais c'est oui c'est la
musique et en fait ça partait de quoi
peut-être d'une chose aussi bête que ça
c'est à dire que
la musique jouait sur quelque chose de
très fins entendre
dire que les gens à l'habitude
d'entendre oui mais j'irai même plus
loin c'est que les gens on n'avait pas
pour leur argent magra à ouï dire que si
jamais je fais
et vous avez payé 150 euros dit allez
vous pouvez faire un second podium voilà
ils ont vécu ça comme ça alors qu'on
fait effectivement ce qui se jouait à ce
moment là dans la musique de berne
puisque c'est celle qu'elle imposait le
plus de questions c'était quelque chose
qui était vraiment entendu
là je joue une chose devait berne qu'il
traite de jeunesse
sa frêle rapidement de n'importe quelle
réalité absolue oui césario vont bien
être ouais
c'était ça et ça donne à la fin
quand on pousse le système jusqu'au bout
en augmentant oui le rapport au silence
puis les gens là on a l'impression sous
perdu nos plus la sensation d'être lié à
quelque chose
c'est pas de la provocation mais y'a
c'est bien il ya l'idée que dire que
quelque chose se casse ou non la chanson
française du meurtre qui a été fait sur
cette musique c'est l'idée de ne pas lui
donner la possibilité c'est le maire de
la poésie c'est pas lui donner la
possibilité d'être entièrement
motivée entraînement fondée sur quelque
chose qui était la peau est plus le
ponant le poème on lui a pas accordé ça
c'est à dire que c'est cette c'est cette
chose là dedans parfum de scandale cette
chose là que je veux faire remonter au
fond c'est que quand le poème altenberg
s'intéresse au bruit que fait la neige
qui tombe sur une flaque d'eau il est
clair que ça va pas faire un énorme
bruit dehors mais pour autant l'idée que
cette flaque que cette neige qui tombe
tombe sur une eau boueuse et c'est sur
une flaque un pur ou je ne sais quoi ils
convoient ce flocons qui à peine le
temps de tomber et c'est quelque chose
qui a une puissance d'évocation en
musique qui peut vraiment faire
maintenant c'est des oeuvres qui sont
complètement rentrer maintenant qu'ils
sont vautrés voilà je me trouve ça
génial oui plus qu'on marque jaune on
est pareils positif que je vais utiliser
non seulement très bleu vraiment le
scandale que ça a fait la création à
l'opéra garnier c'est quand même
beaucoup plus proche de nous c'est pas
1913 dans les années 70 mais le grand
macabre mais qu'est ce qu'il a fait il a
juste comme prologue utiliser les
klaxons voiture de la place à quatre
percussionnistes il les a écrits sous
une forme de hockey de bach
donc les gens venaient de quitter sa
d'en arriver dans la salle est servi
dans la salle pof qu'est ce qu'on leur
envoie la même chose que l'amérique et
qu'ils ont dit on dépasse en foutons je
viens je viens de vous joindre à moi
j'appelle à la vie un pour la retrouver
et c'était la même et je finis là dessus
parce que là c'est bon c'était la même
chose pour malheur avec
quand il avait son quatrième mouvement
son mouvement de la 3e 4e symphonie il
fait venir un violoniste deschamps c'est
à dire qu'il ya un fidèle on appelle sa
fille duncan en crin crin en fête
qui sonne mal qui est moche et c'est a
priori vécu comme ça et bien s'est
retrouvé avec un public contre lui de
part et d'autre c'est à dire que le
pauvre paysan qui avait réussi à mettre
de côté pour avoir avoir une place enfin
l'opéra ou enfin la vienne se retrouve
avec la chose qui fuient devant lui donc
il en qu'il est pas content et quand on
joue à lille n'a jamais voulu voir ça
sur scène dont il n'est pas content non
plus d'aucun pour la première fois il a
réussi un docu monisme fou c'est que le
public s'est trouvé d'accord pour se
liguer contre lui à cause d'un violon
qui venait de de l'expérience qu'il
avait de ça on va c'est un peu cette
musique a pris ce risque et la
fin car j'étais un autre scandale c'est
que malheureusement le temps nous ferait
donc en gros mais on est obligé d'avoir
été obligé d'arrêter il ya plein de
choses dont j'aurais voulu parler
d'ailleurs de ce que vous allez faire
sur un bout de souffle des contraintes
que vous avez donnée avec les rencontres
vous avez fait dans celle du peintre
boltanski et de peter brook
malheureusement on en est au médecin
terreau
mais je vais me souvenir alors on va
venir vous voir surtout voilà mais est
une théâtre et fonctionne pour que ce
soit pas que le concert il ya des
présentations il ya de quoi me
rencontrer il est très doué regret
puisque ce que je vous propose c'est que
quand vous revenez en rencontrent à
nouveau en tout cas moi j'aime beaucoup
parler d'eux de tout ça bravo en tout
cas merci merci